شارك عشره الاف الاسرائيليين في سلسله من
الاحتجاجات المتواصله للاسبوع العاشر ضد
رغبه الائتلاف اليمني المتطرف الحاكم في
تغيير مؤسسه القضاء وتحيد المحكمه العليا
والسيطره على اليه تعيين القضاه واحتشهد
اكثر من خمسين الفا من مدينه حيفا اضافه
الى ثلاثه اضعاف هذا العدد في ميدان رئيسي
في تل ابيب بالاضافه لالاف في مدن ومناطقه
مختلفه ورفع المتظاهرون العلم الاسرائيليه
وشعارات تتهم بنيامنه ياهو وحلفائه من
اليمين المتطرف والعنصريين
المتدينين الاصوليين بالانقلاب على القضاء
والسلطه والنظام السياسي وبالسعي لتحويله
الى دكتاتوريه تهدر فيها حقوق المواطنين
ويسعى لائتلاف الحاكم لتبرئه اعضائه من
تهم فساد
يحاكمون فيها